[Music]  this butterfly was once thought to be  extinct  though rediscovered it remains one of  the world's rarest and most elusive  butterflies  this is the palos verdes blue butterfly  this butterfly is as elusive as it is  beautiful and the brilliance of its blue  wings are only visible when it opens  them  the wings are distinctive with their  brilliant silvery blue colour  the butterfly was thought to be extinct  in the 1980s when it seemed to disappear  without a trace  it wasn't until the 1990s that this  visually striking butterfly was spotted  again  biologists were surprised and delighted  in its existence and a breeding program  was begun to build up the species  though captive breeding has helped  bolster numbers the population is still  low enough to remain on the endangered  list  through careful nurturing and management  this small but mighty butterfly has a  fighting chance  this is the palos verdes blue butterfly  [Music]  you